how will kovit 19 shape our economic
future
the imf estimates the global cost of the
virus
at 28 trillion us dollars in lost output
that's between 2020 and 2025.
but we've heard a lot about how damaging
the pandemic has been for the economy
and people's livelihoods still there may
be some changes for the better
economists hope the environment local
industry and even our social lives
could eventually benefit from the
experience
hello and welcome to your covet 19
special i'm chris coburn berlin
there's so much that we needed to learn
about the coronavirus that we needed to
adapt to
during the pandemic and still the cost
of it has been overwhelming
when it all started dw's ben fazolin
talked to
five top economists about their
predictions for the business world and
our working lives
a year on he spoke to them again in the
hope of garnering a little more
hope
i think you should be confident not over
optimistic but confident
this is one of the most severe crisis
in in the world history we ever had
[Music]
but on the other hand of course we see
also very positive things of
let's say people sitting in the same
boat
no i don't think we have learned enough
i think we're still stumbling our way
forward
so we have amateur drivers hit the
wheels of the global economy
and and that's the main danger we face
the pandemic has increased cooperation
in society there has been a lot of
cooperation across countries it's a big
source
of of innovation where we do need to go
now
is a more inspiring collective
future vision of what we want our
economies to look like
and this is the moment to do it
[Music]
april 2020 was grim where is everyone
now there's light at the end of the
tunnel there's a vaccine
we have a strong instrument in our hands
to fight
this pandemic a year ago it wasn't clear
we would have that
[Music]
a year ago economists were trying to
predict what sort of a recession was
coming
a v signifies a sharp brief decline
followed by a rebound
w is a double dip recession
l is a plunge that stays down low for a
long time
it was nothing like an l-shaped
recession uh
fortunately we would have been far far
worse without that level of government
spending
it was between a v-shaped recession and
something maybe like a w
it was an up and down a roller coaster
situation but at the very end i'm quite
confident that we are now really on the
upward trend
it depends who we refers to
what has become very clear is that we're
looking at a
k shaped recovery
a continued polarization a hollowing out
of the middle class
the concentration of workers in
low-skilled low-paid jobs and then a
concentration of workers and
high-skilled high-paying jobs the
pandemic was the major
dis equalizer i think that is probably
the key issue between rich and poor
after the crisis that this trend is
really accelerating
but what about the record amounts of
money governments are spending to
rebuild economies
this is only going to maintain a status
quo that already wasn't working
we will see more home office more
working from home
and and that means more options for
highly
trained and highly educated workers
we've also seen a push in digitization
and acceleration
again this favors highly educated people
and now post the pullback of some of
these support measures
you can probably expect that for those
that were already having a difficult
time
things will get worse there has
definitely been a wealth transfer again
to the wealthy and like every everything
that happens in in
a western economy the solution is to
make it better by making the wealthy
wealthier there has to be a day of
reckoning for that at some stage i hope
a year ago economist daniel starter told
me just throwing money at the problem
wouldn't work our strategy of the past
30 years
of solving all problems in the economy
by having cheaper money and more credit
and more loans
is coming to an end it didn't
governments have never spent so much
but daniel's still not a fan what has
been the main driver of inequality in
the past
40 years easy credit
much more money which was created lower
interest rates and whenever there was a
crisis instead of having the rich lose
money the seller banks stepping in
so they should rather do their job and
get the financial system back to the
original role of funding productive
investments and not speculation
so if you speculate and you make a
mistake you should lose your money and
should not be rescued
is there something positive that's come
out of all of this
where you see okay the world's woken up
to this
or politicians finally understand
economics well i'm
well no politicians never understand
economics i doubt it to be honest
i see a big risk that politicians now
have the
belief that they are the ones managing
the world
and um i think they have not done a good
job in the corona
crisis i fear is going to be to lead to
less efficient and effective solutions
and therefore i would say it's an excuse
for politicians to grasp more power
getting bolder is going to pay off in
the longer term
because this is the moment to create the
care economy
to upgrade our education systems to put
in place lifelong learning systems
to put in place self-sustaining better
social safety nets for the future
all of that happens now
and what about globalization the
pandemic brought international
trade to a screeching halt the main
change over time i hope will be more
localization
of manufacturing i think that we've got
far too lengthy
supply chains far too much based on
exploiting cheap wages in the rest of
the world
and not developing the domestic economy
where the consumption actually occurs
i do not think that globalization will
be replaced by
regionalization or localization we
shouldn't forget that
locally concentrated production also has
its risks
so what we are heading for i believe is
less concentration let's say on the
cheapest
supplier but more diversification to be
more
resilient in future crisis but this
may even lead to more rather than less
globalization i'm very skeptical from
for instance about supply supply chain
laws
because they split labor markets in poor
countries
trapped in commodities it's not good
that
developing countries poorer countries
will always be
commodity exporters that's that's not
the way
to development to prosperity
the crisis gave us all pause for thought
it gave the environment a break too
but not for long wherever this virus
came from even if it came from the wuhan
lab
the ultimate cause of this crisis has
been
excessive human pressure upon the
biosphere and
we're going to see more and more
instances of that coming back
so the light at the tunnel may be the
fire
of the forest burning ahead of you
bringing your factories down
all of us have seen one dire warning
after another
that talks about um how
how far we have pushed to the limit the
planet
and how our current economic systems
are not compatible with having a more
sustainable and greener economy
we have to change our consumption habits
we'll do that
and maybe we will be more social
interconnection
and maybe also social let's say
coherence when we had it before it has
also shown us that maybe we can travel a
little less
do more things from home uh be and that
alone would be more environmentally
friendly but
of course on balance you know it would
be better to if the next pandemic
didn't come before let's say a hundred
years
or maybe even much later than that
because tackling the calamities at hand
seems to be difficult enough for example
when it comes to having
the right jab to fight the coronavirus
here's our science correspondent
derek williams answering your questions
why is authorization for the chinese and
russian vaccines
being delayed by europe's medical
regulator
under ordinary circumstances so so when
we're not
smack dab in the middle of the largest
global health crisis
in a century um it takes quite a while
for the ema or the european medicines
agency
to carry out scientific evaluations
after phase 3 trials with therapies
and vaccines generally between 9
and 10 months but that's under ordinary
circumstances
in the midst of the pandemic the ema set
up a special task force to help
fast track covet 19 vaccines
a key change is that developers don't
have to wait until
all of their data is final before
submitting it for approval
but have been able to submit it instead
in batches
while while trials are still ongoing a
process called
rolling review both chinese
and russian vaccines are now in this
rolling review
process in the eu but the agency hasn't
made any promises on when
exactly market authorization will be
forthcoming
if it does i'd say there's no question
that politics has played at least a
secondary role
in delaying this process but but that's
far from the only reason
it's taking sabang there have also been
issues
with trial data for some time the ema
said the data being presented by chinese
and
russian developers didn't meet eu
standards for proof of effectiveness
of safety and quality the agency as a
rule
is pretty tight-lipped about the review
process
a chinese vaccine has been in it since
the beginning of may
and and russia's sputnik v since march
but it's still impossible to say
anything firm about when
exactly ema authorization might be
granted
though many other countries around the
world are already using the vaccines
it could take another month or two in
the eu or it could take a lot longer
[Music]
and that wraps up our show for more you
can always hit our website at dw.com
covet19 for now thanks for watching stay
[Music]
safe
you